cow starting off this hour in California
hey cow how are you hi Stacy
thanks so much for having me I'm doing
good hi Rachel rachel is not here this
segment how can I help okay hi so I just
recently started a seventh baby step and
we've got down step number one my
husband and I have been saving and we
got five thousand dollars in our savings
that's what we decided that we had
needed so now we're on step number two
paying off our debt and it basically
consists just of my school loans but
that's still about two hundred twenty
thousand dollars in school debt and 175
thousand of that's going to be forgiven
after 10 years Louis Malle our years ago
no it's not oh oh okay you haven't read
about the student loan forgiveness
program no I I me not there anything
else that I obviously there's something
I don't know
yeah 93 thousand people have made
application in less than a hundred of
God nits oh wow so you don't count on
that yeah what did you what is you're
definitely in for two hundred and twenty
thousand dollars I'm the pharmacist oh
that's good okay good so what do you
make 130 yes how long have you been out
I'm ten years and you spent two hundred
twenty thousand dollars on your pharmacy
degree anything on it well I was in the
military for the first five years and so
I was making minimal two-nothing
payments on that and they didn't I
didn't pay for the pharmacy degree at
all no I joined after I went to school
okay
alright so you're out now are you single
no I'm married with you little one oh
good and how much does your husband like
he only works part-time he's a full-time
dad okay
well you guys are in the middle of a
financial crisis okay you have two
hundred twenty thousand dollars in debt
and what that
as everybody works all the time right
starting right now ready set go and that
means you are going to pick up like er
on the weekends and use your pharmacy
degree and add another $30,000 to your
income working nights and weekends
somewhere else as well so that you can
start attacking this stuff and you guys
are going to have what part of
California are you in northern in
Sacramento okay alright that's a little
more doable thank goodness it's still a
tough still a tough market in terms of
expense but yeah it's not yeah you don't
live in San Diego though that's a good
thing you certainly don't live in San
Jose which is a really good thing so
okay so anyway we're you know you're
gonna have to live on nothing and
increase your income dramatically and
make these student loans go away and so
if we start doing like fifty thousand a
year on student loans then it's going to
take you about four to five years to
clear these student loans but that's
going to involve your income increasing
and his income increasing and you guys
are living on nothing beans and rice
rice and beans you don't need to see the
inside of a restaurant unless you're
working there mm-hm okay okay
you are home scorched-earth because hey
look at what look at what you've been
doing for the last since you got out of
school what ten years yeah
what you've been doing towards your dad
let me help you with what you did
towards your dad since then nothing yeah
you have got to change something it's
not working and the more dramatic your
change and deeper your sacrifice the
more dramatic your success story is
going to be in terms of the speed of it
because the formula is the deeper you
cut and the more you work the more money
is thrown towards this debt and the
faster you get out so if you want to be
a band-aid off slowly girl you can do
that over five years I'm a band-aid off
fast guy and I'm gonna do this in about
two and a half years and then I'm gonna
sleep but I'm not gonna sleep much
during that first two and a half yeah I
was really banking on that you to
forgiveness so this kind of fits me and
there's only different perspective
yeah I'm sorry I wish I wish they were
gonna forgive it but they're not yeah in
practical fact I mean the program the
program is still in place and you can
look up the website and it still says
all the same crap it's always yeah I've
been applying and I'm just doing annual
updates with that yeah and they don't
give you approval they just I just
accept your information and move on and
then when you get to the end of it they
have not been forgiving them because
they're finding somebody didn't do
something right one time you're what
late on one payment any time during the
two years you're baked you know you
don't you're not in falling into
whatever category for any period of time
you're baked and so it's a complete scam
and I wish they would just wave their
wand and get well I sort of wish they'd
wave the wand and forgive them but
they're not going to they're not going
to it's not gonna happen so you've got
to count on you not the government
to fix this problem and that's what I
would do if I were in your shoes because
we're pretty sure at this point
Elizabeth Warren's not going to get
elected so your student loans are not
going to be forgiven Bernie's not going
to do it I hope that helps